The thing about building a company
is that inevitably things go wrong, and bad
things happen.
You don’t want that to happen, you don’t
anticipate when that happens, but it is inevitable
in the lifecycle of any company.
When that happens the best way to react to
that is to use it as a learning lab.
Use it as an opportunity to call everybody
together and really have a laboratory, have
a workshop, have an understanding of: how
do we unpack what happened and why it all
happened with no blame but with understanding
of the systems that got us here, and then
how do we think about how do you respond right
now together, and then how do you move forward
from there, both in terms of establishing
maybe new procedures, establishing some new
policies, some even new ways of thinking,
some new operational tactics, but then also
this is equally important, how does the company
and the CEO and the team around him or her
successfully move on emotionally, kind of
create a new point of view recognizing that
that was in the past and there’s the future
to look too?
You can’t change the past, you can only
change the future.
So the best way to debrief any bad thing that
happened, any problem is just to go down the
tiers of “Why.”
And so you start with—so let’s assume
that the project that you’re working on
is late, let’s assume it’s a product release,
and that it is now definitely not going to
make its deadline, and it’s probably three
or six months late.
First of all it’s important just to create
an environment where people can talk freely
and not feel blamed, because we’re just
debriefing to understand what happened.
So it’s about understanding the structure
of it not looking to finger point.
But the first question is, why?
So why was the release late?
Well, engineering, for example, didn’t deliver
the code on time.
Why didn’t engineering deliver the code
on time?
Because they weren’t given the specs early
enough.
Why weren’t they given the specs early enough?
Because product didn’t get them to them
early enough.
Why didn’t product to get them to them early
enough Because product didn’t understand
from marketing the requirements early enough.
So if you keep going down those and you understand
why did marketing not get them early enough,
it’s because they didn’t have a good plan
to get the customer data they needed to, then
you can take a look at what went wrong here.
Is it about we need to tighten up our process
(which is very often true, especially with
startups)?
Is it that we need to have a better timeframe
for deliverables (which is often very true
when you’re working on complicated multi-domain
projects)?
Or do we just forecast incorrectly?
Did we not take into account all the multiple
steps that leads to the product release, and
that’s often very true as well?
And maybe why didn’t we take into account
the multiple steps?
Because there wasn’t one person in charge.
Great.
So going forward we know that we need to all
take into account the multiple steps, and
declare one person the owner of the project
overall, and let’s try those two interventions,
those two changes, and that’s going to help
us have more excellence in operations.